You are listening to radiolab
radio from W N Y s e.
Okay. I'm Jad Abumrad. I'm Robert
Krulwich, Radiolab and today, well, today,
yes,
the story of an ax wielding nun
coming through a window to smack some
staphylococcus and take you back to
the future. Exactly the story it goes,
I'm not getting a sense. I
don't know if you will. Okay,
well the story comes in two parts,
both from our producer Latif Nasser,
and here's part one.
So the way the story
goes, it starts in 1928
1928 Alexander Fleming, the story goes,
who knows if it's apocryphal or not,
is growing staph staphylococcus
in his lab. That's Maryn Mckenna.
She's a science writer
and staff is a bacterium.
It lives on our skin and especially
like parts of the body that are warm and
damp. So it likes to be just up our noses
or on our genitals or in our armpits,
places like that. And
generally it's no big deal.
It doesn't really do us any harm,
but if it gets into a scratch or a cut
and makes its way inside our bodies,
staff goes from being this
benign companion to being
potentially deadly. Anyway,
London 1928 Fleming has growing staff
in his lab in these little petri dishes
and he was a slob
basically, and he goes on a vacation.
He leaves his petri dishes
covering bacteria just
around leaves his window open
and something blows across his lab plates.
Some tiny little spec of a thing just
floats in through the window and comes to
arrest on one of those petri
dishes. And so a few weeks later,
Fleming finally back from vacation.
He needs to use those lab plates again
and he and his assistant go to clean them
off. Yeah,
I mean you'd imagine that he
would seed some real lush,
nice furry lawn of staff just over flowing
right out of the plate because it's
been sitting there for so long.
It's been a staff party, but on one
of the plates that they pick up,
they realize that,
cool,
it's almost polka dot. It's got
little dead zones all over it.
Little patches where the staff is dead,
dead, dead. Something
blew through the window,
landed in the dish and
starts killing the bacteria.
Yeah, and so when Fleming
looks down at his plate,
he sees that at the center of these,
you know, staff dead zones, uh,
there's a tiny speck of
natural mold. Oh, mo.
And they realize that that mold is
expressing a compound that is killing the
staff around it. It's like emanating
rays of death. What was the compound?
That compound was called
[inaudible],
the first true antibiotic infectious
diseases that had been killing people for
as long as we had been.
People suddenly could be stopped and
it just blew in through the window.
That is the, that is the story that's
always been told. However it got there,
it was, it was amazing. It was a miracle.
It was called a miracle drug. Right?
I mean, it was just, it was,
it really was a moment when the world
changed when Fleming was put on the cover
of Time magazine. This is
1944 height of World War II.
It was a picture of his face and the,
the banner on the cover said
his penicillin will save
more lives than we're can
spend.
[inaudible] but,
and this is, um, I had no idea about this.
Virtually at the exact same time when
Fleming's faces on the cover of Time
magazine, like two months later, um,
this Stanford researcher publishes that
he has found five different streams of
staff.
The do not respond to
penicillin. Really? Yeah.
This is happening while he's on the
cover, virtually the exact same moment.
And it's the first sign that staff has
responded to the penicillin in the world
by developing resistance to almost
like a separate history. So in wheeler,
the era of penicillin was over before
it began, almost before it began,
before it's even released
to the general public. Wow.
And that penicillin resistant staff
moves across the globe.
And in 1957 in Cleveland,
some scientists gather together
and they are in a panic.
They have no idea why they've lost
the antibiotic miracle so quickly.
So scientists across the globe put their
brains together and try to come up with
a new drug next amazing thing.
And in 1960 they get methicillin.
Oh
and it works for about
11 months, 11 months.
And so we started this arms race.
There was a bug and then there
was a drunk that took care of it,
and then there was a better bug
drug bug drug bugs. Right, exactly.
I actually found this list. Do
you want to hear it? Yeah. Okay.
So streptomycin 1943 resistance,
1948 methicillin 1960
resistance in 1961 clindamycin.
1969 resistance. 1970 wow.
You can think of it as leap frog
or you can think of it as a game of
whac-a-mole, ampicillin,
1961 then 1973 so that's a
little carbenicillin released.
1964 resistance. 1974 they're getting
better. They're getting better.
There were always more trunks.
Drug development was doing really
well for a really long time.
Hyper Cillin introduced 1980 resistance,
1981 but after the year
2000 drug companies begin to
realize it's not really in
their best interest to
make antibiotics anymore.
And the end I have on
this list is linezolid,
which is introduced 2000 resistance,
2002 wow. There are a few more,
but you get the idea antibiotic approvals,
the entry of new drugs to the market
just kind of fell off a cliff. Why?
Well to it takes 10 years and $1 billion
to get to the point where the drug is
marketable. But as soon as you
get the drug on the market,
the resistance clock is running.
So you probably won't make your money
back. And as you've probably heard,
we now have these situations,
well,
frightening new warning from the Centers
for disease control about the spread of
a string of germ where literally nothing
works so called super bugs are now
turning up in hospitals and patient dies.
There are nail bugs that
can resist all of our drugs.
I have seen physicians
breakdown weeping over this.
It's not the way that medicine
is supposed to fail anymore,
but it does.
I mean I know that that possibly the,
the origin story of
penicillin, this is apocryphal.
So this is all a little
suspect, but you know,
just do enjoy imagining for a moment.
Like it just seems like if that happened,
let's just open up a bunch more windows,
just something out of blow in and we
can wait a long time. Right. I mean,
we had staff had been around
for Millennia before 1928
but you know,
the whole reason I wanted to do this
story is because kind of there is a new
window. It's a different
kind of window though.
Not to not a window nexus and
petri dishes, not a window
nexus and petri dishes.
Kind of a window next
to somebody, few dishes,
but a totally different kind of window.
What kind of window is it? Well,
I'm about to tell you that it's
something blow into the window. Yeah,
but it's not mold. It's
way more fun than mold it.
It carries an ax. How about
that? So it's a person maybe
I don't even know what
I'm referring to anymore.
Hello.
This is Isabelle and the birds calling
all the way from Montevideo. Uruguay.
Radiolab is supported in part by
the Alfred p Sloan Foundation,
enhancing public understanding of science
and technology in the modern world.
More information about Sloan
at www dot Sloane. Dot.
Bork. All right guys. Ciao.
This is Brian Marks in
Los Angeles, California.
Radiolab is supported
by penguin random house.
The best books of the year lists are
out, but how will you read them all?
Try them on audio. Listen to Colson
Whitehead's, the underground railroad,
Brit Bennett's the mothers, John
Grisham's, the whistler, and many more.
To keep up with all the hot
titles of the year visit.
Try audio books.com back slash w n Y
C for sample clips and start listening
today.
Hi, my name is Jacob. I'm calling
from Oak Harbor. Washington.
Radiolab is supported by intercontinental
hotels and resorts presenting their
podcast series stories of
the intercontinental life.
Take a journey into the intercontinental
life and hear stories about empathy as
you learn about other cultures
and expand your understanding.
Discover culinary insights from chef
Martha Ortiz of Mexico or visit Katherine
Sargent, the first female master
tailor to open her own shop in London.
Explore philosophy for everyday
life with authors and experts,
and discuss the power of empathy and the
importance of forming connections with
the world around us.
Download the stories of the
intercontinental life on iTunes.
Uh, part two. Yep. Okay. Hey, I'm Jad
I boom. Rod. Hi, I'm Robert Krulwich.
This is Radiolab. We're
ready now for part two.
Now remember when part one ended,
there was a window open and
something was going to come through.
We don't know what to do. We know it's
not mold. Yeah, we know it's not mold.
So whatever it is, whatever
it was, whatever it will
be, we will hear about it.
Now from our reporter Latif Nasser, well,
actually there is this story about
these two women who did open a window,
uh, to, to an alien and distant land. Um,
and actually in a way it's a
story about re-imagining the past,
but to me it's a, it's a, it's a,
it's a story about a friendship.
Hey everybody. Hello again. Hello again.
It's a story about an unlikely
friendship. Um, it's a bloody field.
It's a buddy. Yeah, it's a buddy
movie. Okay. So, yeah, tell us,
maybe just walk us through it. Right.
So, okay, so you have, um, hello,
I'm Dr. Christina Lee,
Christina and I'm an associate professor
in Viking studies at the school of
English at the University of
Nottingham. She's a historian.
And then you also have, hi,
I'm Freya Harrison. Freya.
I'm a research fellow in the center for
biomolecular sciences at the University
of Nottingham and free up free as a
microbiologist. She studies bacteria.
We'll start with her. Okay.
So most of my work is about,
so we're looking at how
bacteria, if all of during very,
very long lived infections, but
like my big hobby is
Anglosaxon Viking reenactment
[inaudible] interest
in the history and uh,
mainly in dressing up as a warrior and
going to fight club every Wednesday night
and learning to use the weapons. Yeah.
So this is actually not free as
group. This is a group in New Jersey,
but basically they do the same thing.
Hundreds of people go out into, you know,
some field with some dulled
weapons, everything from swords,
spears, axes,
and we give each other a jolly good
fashioning and have a good time.
I only mentioned this cause
it, it actually plays into
the story. Well it was,
it was really a nice sort
of coincidence really.
So 2012 a few years after
finishing her doctorate,
Freya goes off to work at
the University of Nottingham.
Nottingham is one of the places in the
UK, not only for, for microbiology,
but for sort of Anglo
Saxon in Viking history.
And she goes there to study
microbes, but she figures, hey,
why not while I'm here,
brush up on my old English with her
h m will here, it's [inaudible].
I'd studied some old English to a level
where I could sort of read and fat and
speak a little bit. Let's stand on Nif
Nikita. She figured, Hey, she could,
she could be better. And if she did,
she would get deeper into
the whole reenactment thing.
So I rather cheekily emailed
the school of English,
his old English reading group. That's
where she met Christina, the historian.
And I thought one point Christina, the
historian asks freer like what do you do?
And Fred said, you know, my day
job is that I'm a microbiologist,
but on evenings and
weekends I'm a history nerd.
And Christina said the moment she heard
that and just kind of thought I found my
kindred spirit here
because she was like, wow,
I'm like your mirror image
because I'm a historian by day,
but by night I'm a microbiology nerd.
I've been interested in infectious
disease for quite a long time. Which um,
I don't, I don't find any kind
of friends in my department.
She told me she's the kind of
person who would, you know,
watch Ebola coverage on the news
and not be able to stop watching.
So eventually they start talking
about historical diseases.
So like how would people back then
have treated something like, you know,
Ebola, Freya is especially interested
in this because she, for her struggle,
reenactment is developing this nun
character who goes off and heels people.
But anyway, so they're
talking back and forth.
And then to cut a long story short,
they find themselves both interested
in this one particular book.
It's known as boat's leach book. This is
about 1100 years old. What's it called?
Bolt balls. What? Bolds leach
book as nothing to do with no hat.
Oh,
even though it just spelled as B Zeno
d it is indeed leach like leach like a,
like a leach, like a little worm. It
grabs onto your, your blood? No, no.
It comes from the old English word legend,
which is actually a healer or a doctor.
So is it that little squeaky animals
are called leaches because they're
medicinal, not the other way around. So
the doctor wasn't named for the leads.
The lead was named for the
doctors. And Bald is the,
as a man the guy wrote, we think it's
a guy, we think it's like a nice name.
And what is this book? So it's kind
of like this old healers handbook.
It's filled with these potions and cures.
The original manuscript is in
the British library locked away,
but 21st century very kind.
People have digitize the original
old English text and put it online.
So Christina and Freya bring it up
and they start going through all the
remedies. And you know,
as it describes to you remedies for
stuff that is a little bit different.
You know, things like phone Odell vote
for no money on possession by the devil,
which according to this leach book,
the remedy for someone who is possessed
by the devil is you view the rank and
Lutheran make this kind of like foul brew.
You make them drink it and it'll
make them vomit out the devil.
And then there's another remedy for warts.
This shale we at our new auto zone and
all I'm going to say about that one is
that it involves Helen's
urine and mouse blood.
And then things like Muncie, I
taught around a, how should we say,
make your husband more physically
attentive or less physically attentive,
whichever you,
whichever direction you need to moderate
it or towed blood drink on [inaudible]
Nestea actually it's just you boil boiler,
plant and some water and give
it to the guy. Oh yeah. Anyway,
so free and Christina are going through
this Veatch book looking for some kind
of wounds thing. It was clearly
an infection, some posse, uh,
something we could clearly say that
that's bacteria. And eventually they,
they find an entry at the end of
the recipe. It says an old English,
say Beth's de la [inaudible]
still nudged them.
The best medicine. The best
medicine. Yeah. Move over. Laughter.
Yeah. And we thought, how
can we not try this one?
What was the best medicine for?
So it said it was for a lump in the eye.
It's anticoag when in holding these days
if you get a course like that could be
something like a watch. Right?
But there is a suggestion by
archeologists that eye infection was,
was rife amongst the Anglo Saxons
because you lived in buildings where you,
you had smoke going on,
you look crammed together.
So that could also be
a sty. What is a STI?
It's an infection of an
eyelash follicle. You Rub,
it itches and then it gets scrolling.
Causes quite a nasty red lumps of
STI in your eyes. Stay in your eye.
Now it just so happens that the
bacteria that causes the signer I is
staphylococcus Aureus staph. Oh, the
same stuff as the mister window man.
Penicillin man. Exactly.
And we just thought,
wouldn't it be nice to have a bit of spare
time and add a couple of hundred quid
to buy the ingredients and just give
this a go? Yes, let's give it a try.
You know, why, why the hell
not? And matter of fact
we thought that two video recently
producer Matt Kielty and I went to my tiny
apartment in the city and we tried to
cook it up to, are you ready to cook? Oh,
I'm ready to cut. I've got this recipe
here. Please read it. Go for it.
Okay. It goes like this
with one name crop. That's
the first line of the recipe.
And right off the bat for Christina
and Freya, there's a problem.
That first ingredient would
crop the ouch crop latch.
Christina said it was quite difficult
to translate and nobody quite knows what
it is, but luckily just a
couple of words over was a clue.
Then Garlia they May
2nd ingredient garlic,
which is an allium spaces and crop
latch. We know this was another allium.
That's what the dictionary
of old English, um,
tells us significant probably what they
were dealing with as an onion or leak.
We didn't know which
one. So we thought, okay,
we'll try one that has
onion and one that has leak.
Now you knew the recipe doesn't
cover this, but we did it anyway. Um,
peel the onion, chop it
up. The same for the Gar.
Like the recipe doesn't tell you how
much it just tells you mine's off.
So you take out the measuring cup. So
you measure it in equal amounts? Yeah.
You call them mounts and there's a
pestle and then after that, okay.
It says it canoe
hounded well together. Okay.
We really pounded and pounded. Freya did
lots and lots of time
with a mortar and pestle.
Muscles built up from wielding a
sword for pounding the ingredients,
starting to be more of
a mush third ingredient.
The next one was definitely something
you wouldn't have knocking around in your
kitchen and fe, rs. Yeah. Lung Bay.
I am Fairleigh school ox girl, bovine
bio from a, from a cow's gallbladder.
What do you have to kill the
cow and then go reach it.
It's actually a very standard
ingredient in microbiology labs.
Ox Bile today in 2015 you can but
should not just buy it on the Internet.
Here we go, here we go.
And so you take the ox bile added to
the onion and garlic and then the fourth
ingredient they name a win
wine and wine, red wine,
white wine like Whoa, why are we
talking about, this is the thing.
So we had quite a discussion about what
type of wine should we use and we don't
know really, did they have red
wine that they have white wine?
What was the alcohol content?
But I did a bit of a bit of detective
work and you figured out that the
monastery where this Leech
book was written, well they,
she figured out where their
vineyard was just down the road.
This is modern organic vineyard.
So they used that wine.
Can we kill Dave Yolie and [inaudible] I
just want to point out how difficult it
is to find English line. We had to
use Italian, but it mainly with sue
[inaudible] on artifact. Once
you get all that stuff together,
you're under the final
ingredient, the fifth ingredient.
It was actually that you're specifically
told that you have to mix these
ingredients together in a brass or
a bronze pot. Um, I don't have one.
Um, so we had to sort of
add pieces of, you know,
of copper that would've been
available to people at the time.
So they had to do some research,
but they figured out that the copper of
today that is most like the copper of a
millennium ago was actually
taught trench brass,
which is what's used to standard in
plumbing fittings. Pennies in there.
We actually use penny's worth,
couldn't show it looks and
smells like quite a nice,
quite a nice summer
suit. It looks awful. Oh,
that's so gross.
Clearly we botched this whole thing
not to stand the neonics on them,
RF fatter. And uh, finally we're going
to cover it. Okay. We're covering it.
The directions say we have to let
the whole thing sit for awhile.
That has to be stored
for nine days and nights.
Okay. That's it. One day
goes by, two days, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine, nine days later.
All right, here we go. You
Ready? All. Alright, here we go.
And nipped on them. Our
Arvato outer ring through Cla.
Then you have to strain it through
a cloth. The liquid that comes off,
you apply to the person's
eye or the liquid and
[inaudible] say bets. Lunch. Now,
clearly we didn't have any staff to
try this out on, but Freya in her lab,
she made these mock wounds with these
little plugs of, of, of Collagen,
so it's a bit like Jelly.
Basically it's like a,
like a goopy substance made to be kind
of like a flesh wound and we infect these
wounds with bacteria, with the staff.
Then they put this thousand year old
recipe that had been standing there for
nine days. They put it on the
bacteria that was in the fake wound.
We'd obviously where we didn't think
this was going to work. Nope. We thought,
you know, we'll given the ingredients,
we might see some small
killing effect on the bacteria,
but it won't be anything
to write home about.
They thought maybe you'd
killed 10% 20% of the bacteria.
But then when they came back the
next day, it was a staff massacre.
It went on a rampage and
went on a staff rampage.
It was killing, you know,
99.99999% of these bacterial cells.
Yeah.
First we thought we made some sort of
mistake and this was some kind of fluke,
you know, we'd, we'd accidentally mixed
up our plates or mislabeled something.
So
[inaudible]
we run the entire experiment again.
They grab ingredients, Mash them up,
put them on some bacteria
and it happens again.
Just absolutely wiped out the
bacteria and held them dead.
And he tried a third time and a fourth
and fifth and it works every time.
And this is this, this
is just something you,
you really don't see in
your career. Some test.
And eventually they escalated
from just regular staff to,
to Murcia to the
methicillin-resistant stuff.
And this is one of the
bad ones. Super Bug,
new government data estimate that about
2000 people are dying of community-based
Marissa every year. This one is very
dangerous. It's so Christina and Freya,
they sent some of bald brew to one
of their collaborators in the states.
Oh, collaborator, Kendra Rimbaud in
Lubbock in Texas. Kendra took this stuff,
put it on some Murcia bacteria,
and then a week later sent
free and Christina and email.
And I think it was actually a
three word response. I thought.
I think she just simply
said, what the fuck, what the
ball's best medicine had just
wreaked havoc on the Mercer.
It killed 90% of them. This is
beyond their wildest dreams now free.
And Christina made very clear that
this is not yet a miracle drug. I mean,
it's not even been tested in humans.
So absolutely do not do this at home.
They don't even know if this
is safe. It might be the,
if you don't do it in exactly the way
we did, nasty fungus could grow in it,
give you a worse infection. So, uh,
we should not have done this, this,
Masonite, we
dumped ours down the drain.
But the thing about this whole story that
is so intriguing and so cool to me is
this time travel thing,
which is so strange.
Like it's like the idea that
something a thousand years ago,
uh, like a bullet forge a
thousand years ago, we could,
we could use it now and
then it could work that,
that the time travel dimension
of that is so weird to me.
It kind of makes you think differently
about, I don't know, progress.
So without further ado,
Dr. Christina Lee and Dr Fred Harrison,
and they're going to talk to
us about some ancient biotechs.
For example, just a few weeks ago, uh,
Freya and Christina got up in front
of the Royal Society of chemists.
Thank you very much. And it is
an absolute pleasure to be here.
Large Hotel conference room a hundred
or so people up free actually, uh,
got up on stage dressed as a nun. Okay.
So this is one interpretation of water
and Anglo Saxon scientist may have look
likes and they presented the results.
Next ingredient is
particularly the cooking demo.
And then at some point Christina
said something really interesting.
She was like, okay,
sure we want to write this off because
it has demons and dragons and elves in
it, but are we sure that we know
what they meant by those words?
Like for example, I'll
run the days which asks,
you sing for Avid Marias
and we would say, oh,
that's so superstitious. This is
all in their heads. But there again,
we should also remember this is a
period when people do not have watchers.
You do not have your nurse, you
know, so that's got the watch.
Everybody knows the album.
Maria, everybody knows the
length of an album, Maria,
so maybe it's,
maybe it's take this medicine and wait
20 minutes and I know how to standardize
20 minutes, which is three of them.
Maria's four other Maria's may even,
that's fast.
It may appear one way and it's in
fact could be a totally different way.
It suggests that the,
in order to time travel,
you have to somehow, God,
it's like we don't even have the language
people to understand what they were
doing. There's the effective,
there's a phrase that the
past is a foreign country
like boys. We need to learn the
language of the doctors of that time.
We need to kind of be
a little bit less, um,
dismissive and learn a little bit
more, you know, stuff from them.
I learned a bit of humility this
way. Here's the reason why this is
whole confusing to me.
So 1100 years is a crazy long
time for humans and for bacteria.
That's like an exponentially
crazy long time.
So how is it that something that this
man bald was doing to these bacteria then
like, like it's not even the same
bacteria? How could that even work?
That's a, that's an awesome question. So,
so one thing we've got
to think about is, well,
why did these medicines drop out of use?
And maybe it's because when the week
used the bacteria of old resistance,
but now a thousand years later when
these medicines have not been used,
you'd expect that resistance to be lost.
This is something that Marin
Mckenna mentioned to Zorn and I
that sometimes when you take
a drug out of circulation,
sometimes resistance will
decline. That doesn't always work,
but sometimes the resistance does decline.
So if we had been using this compound
through the ensuing thousand years,
then maybe it wouldn't work. So this
is an interesting discovery there.
Like what worked once
and then was resisted.
You give it a rest,
it can work again and it will be resisted
and you put it to rest and if you had
enough different, if you could go to
different places and the different paths,
did you go to China where they now got
all these people studying Chinese cures
and Arab cures? You could come up with a,
with a rich historical cocktail of
armamentarium that will work if you bring
them in, take them out, bring them
in, take them out and the whole world,
the whole world of the past then
becomes the food of your future sort of.
So it's also a positive.
Like now I have a suddenly an
image that it's possible that that,
this is Soren wheeler by the way,
in conversation with Mary Mckenna Latif
that a thousand years ago these folks
went through what we went through
with penicillin and that they,
this guy wrote something in the book and
it's actually called the best medicine.
He probably got on the cover of
whatever their version of time was,
their Nobel prize and everybody
celebrated and then years later sties were
coming back and the garlic wine didn't
work anymore and they stopped using it
and it got put away and then here we
are and we discover it and it's been put
away long enough that like then, then now
I'm thinking about future some future.
It's civilization digs up and old
medical textbook that was in some dusty
whatever and discovers penicillin
and it works. Did we,
did I lose you on that ma'am? No,
no. I'm still with you. I'm just,
I don't know. It just seemed like,
it seems like such a great
hypothetical construction.
I just didn't really know what
I could add to with this. Sorry.
[inaudible]
producer,
lots of Nasser with hope and Soren
Wheeler and a produced by Matthew Kielty.
Special thanks to Sarah too. Steve
Diggle, Andrew, Alexandra rider,
and Justin Parker, who came down from
Yale to be our old English readers,
to Jean Moreau from the Gotham early
music scene at the Marcia young on the
medieval harp column, Monroe of Tadcaster,
and on the rest of the barren eve iron
buck. Not totally sure what that is,
but I know they helped us out and I
guess we should help ourselves out of the
door quickly through the window.
I'm Chad, I'm Robert Krulwich.
Thanks for listening.